Film Courage: Pamela with romantic comedies, is falling
in love really supposed to be funny?
Pamela Jaye Smith: Well falling in love seldom is funny. Now
it's hopefully fun, but I think what
romantic comedies and the funny look at
the situations can do for us is it can
make it easier for us to take a look at
what happens and how frightened we
sometimes get if the changes that are
happening when we start falling in love
and the resistance that comes from
within and often from without you know
from friends and family who know what
are you doing with that person and maybe
society's strictures against who you're
falling in love with so to take a
comedic look at some of those situations
can be helpful because then you can go
oh okay other people have faced this
kind of situation here are some
solutions maybe we can work that out too
I know in looking at your book romantic
comedies you used one of the case
studies of I think my Big Fat Greek
Wedding and sounds like we're talking a
lot of the similar things where the out
the family was so strong that they only
wanted you know they were very
possessive and also too they had her
sort of as this one type of person and
kind of gave her the impression she
couldn't have another type that that was
the beauty of the film that two
opposites came together yes it's a very
good example of that and I think it's
also a good example when we say falling
in love note the word falling okay
you're going from one position as the
daughter who always does it this way as
the member of the family who this is the
way we do it you're falling into a
different realm and I've often wondered
though why we don't like slide into love
okay it's not a horizontal movement or
why we don't rise into love but of
course if it's well done you do rise up
you do have that that uplifting of your
spirit but falling in love you're
falling off that level where you've been
you're going to a different realm it's a
different world and so I think the
beauty of romance
to comedies is that it can make it a
little bit more palatable to take a look
at the things that happen to us now why
do people love romantic comedies and I
realize not everybody does but we all
have a soft spot for at least one that's
that's true we all we all do have a soft
spot for at least one I will admit when
the publishers came and we were talking
about a new book Kenley said oh you know
there's this study that's been done and
we think that maybe that would make a
good book well what was it said well
couples who watch romantic comedies
together versus the other group of
couples who went to couples therapy an
amazing thing happened the stay together
rate was higher for those who watched
comedies together and talked about them
then it was for those who went to
couples therapy now I still think
couples therapy is a good idea but wait
until you get to that point romantic
comedies now you say well does everybody
like romantic comedies frankly I didn't
that much when Ken and I were talking
about this and he said well we think
you'd be a good person to write this
book I said uh you know I do mythology
and military stuff right and adventure
you guys no no no you you'll do a good
job with it well thanks to he and
Michael we see of Michael we see
productions it was a group effort on
constructing how the chapters would be
laid out and how we'd approach each film
so me a person who was not that much of
a rom-com fan I actually became one
through the process of writing this book
well we want to talk to you about
structure and archetypes and even a
crossover of Mythology versus some of
the romantic comedy themes why do people
set out to write romantic comedies why
do you feel that it's there's a lot of
people in Hollywood pitching these
scripts I think the reason that a
shaundra comes into a trend or a fad is
often the success of a film or a TV show
in
at particularly genre example being
zombie stories I mean for years when we
go to the great American pitchfest and
you look at what people are looking for
it was zombie this zombie that vampire
horror thriller give me some more
zombies for the last couple of years no
one's asking for zombies okay so genres
cycle in and out of popularity but I
think romantic comedies tend to be
consistent because the people who write
them have had some kind of an experience
that they want to share with the world
or maybe okay so I have this theory and
I think facts will prove me out winners
right history losers write about love
because the losers aren't doing anything
they lost in love so they're the ones
who'll write about love and idealize it
and how they think it should be so I
think a lot of the people who write
romantic comedies are those who are
trying to create a reality that they
could inhabit yeah and then sometimes
it's because well gee that's what the
market is looking for because some
writers do right towards the markets
although we're always told you'll get a
much better story if you write it from
here or from here rather than oh yeah
it's gonna be popular it's going to make
a billion dollars love is at the center
of so many people's lives whether it's
they've got plenty or they don't and so
a romantic comedy can be a way of
dealing with that for yourself I think
and also sometimes either warning or
encouraging other people about falling
in love
so that and this is no pun intended but
always a bridesmaid never a bride kind
of a feeling and so they feel like they
have to somehow fulfill that on paper
and through a film I think so and the
the film 27 dresses is a very good
example of that
someone who is always a bridesmaid was
always helping other people but she
never had her own love and so through
the course of that story it's about how
she comes to realize that you know she
does deserve love and she's been helping
all these other people maybe it's time
to look after herself so again who
writes romantic comedies
I had one writer friend who is a very
good writer and he wrote a romantic
comedy was starting it when he was
dating this girl and he was really in
love and then they broke up and oh my
goodness that script changed and it
turned into a horror film
I said now you you are aware of what's
going on here aren't you so how one
feels about love at the moment is
certainly going to dictate the kind of
story that you write and I think we
would all be well served by having more
stories that do put forth as the
romantic comedies in the book do joy
dignity
passion and integrity when relating to
love let's say a writer decides they
would like to write a romantic comedy
and it's for not just the market but for
their own catharsis or need to tell
stories so what should they know before
they even put one word down on the page
about writing romantic comedies I think
in writing romantic comedies one of the
most important things to remember is
that it's a three part trip now not
necessarily three acts but there are
three things that need to happen this is
that this is the genre boy meets girl
boy loses girl boy gets girl back yet
gotta have all that now or it can be you
know girl meets boy girl loses boy girl
meets girl boy meets whatever but you
need to have that that initial spark
that we see them feeling for each other
and we go yeah there's something there
even if it's they're both fighting it
right you know
you're not my type oh no I never go with
someone like you but you know oh yeah
sparks are flying and then there is that
split and it looks like it's over and
then we spend quite some time watching
one of them at least try to figure out
how to get the other person back so it's
that struggle if you will to regain or
to claim what you saw in that first part
of the film and then the third part is
the rien gauging and seeing how that
works now in romantic dramas the third
part might not end well
it might be a tragedy and they don't get
together but even then you want to feel
that you know what they have lost now in
a romantic comedy we want them to get
back together this echoes interestingly
enough the myth of Orpheus enter a DJ
that three parts of girl meets boy girl
loses boy girl gets boy back is an echo
of the ancient Greek myth about Orpheus
and or a DJ they're madly in love it's
their wedding day and she goes off to
pick some flowers and gets bitten by a
poisonous snake dies goes to Hades
Orpheus who was the first rock star he
was a musician and they said he was so
good and so magnetic and charismatic
that he he'd be walking down the lane
playing music and the trees would uproot
themselves and the rocks would grow legs
to follow after him because his music
was so compelling so he loses his wife
his beloved is dead and gone
he stops playing he stops singing and
the world around him starts to go gray
to lose its colour because of lost love
so you've had the first part they're
together they're happy they're ecstatic
then the separation and
this instance of the myth it's very dark
and the whole world suffers because of
their loss in a romantic comedy it
usually isn't that big of an effect but
a lot of people do suffer when somebody
breaks up you know whether it's the
friend who goes I'm so tired of hearing
the same story please go out with me
tonight and meet some more people or the
parents who are saying oh dear you'll
find more there's more fish in the sea
no I don't want fish I want him so that
separation then reflects that myth and
in the mythic story
Orpheus says I got to get her back and
the goddess of love Aphrodite says hang
on here just a minute she goes and talks
to Hades the king of the underworld and
they have a little thing together and
she's oh come on the kids are in love
things aren't going well up there let
them get back together and Hades says
okay fine
but he can't talk to her and he can't
look at her but if he can get her to
follow him up back into the upper world
then yeah okay she can be alive again
and the story's very sad and it's
spawned a number of wonderful operas and
and movies he goes into the underworld
he finds his love so romantic comedy
right you search out the beloved you're
willing to try anything and but they're
often strings attached and that's where
they can get so fun in that that part -
of a romantic comedy what are the
barriers what are the hoops you have to
go through what are the rings of fire to
get back that person that you love right
well Orpheus gets down to the underworld
and he sees her a DJ he starts playing
and he spots it from a distance because
he's not supposed to look at every -
that's her so he starts walking back up
and playing and singing and she hears
him and starts to follow but and here's
where you also find a great echo for
your romantic comedy scripts on the way
up she keeps saying to him
obvious is it you won't you look at me
what is it tell me something tell me
it's you tell me you love me but he
can't he can't or it'll ruin everything
now in some of the stories he just can't
resist and his heart is breaking so he
turns around and looks at her and holds
out his hand and even though he's made
it over the threshold of the underworld
she hasn't
and she gets zapped back down and
they're separated forever now that's a
tragedy but in a romantic comedy we're
gonna do the other version and then that
version
Aphrodite goes back to Hades and she
says Oh seriously come on I mean they
were that close and the kids are in love
and you know what love does don't you
and so he just goes yeah okay fine
okay fine taker so Orpheus and or DHA
get reunited so we have that tragedy as
the format the mythic pattern for
romantic comedies now this is sort of a
loaded question but why are there so
many bad romantic comedies and then
maybe it's just my own opinion what are
they doing wrong the criteria that I
used to select the film's to go into
this book were for these stories had to
embody and promote at least one
hopefully more of these four qualities
joy dignity passion and integrity a lot
of romantic comedies do not therefore
they are maybe entertaining but they're
shallow and there's nothing wrong with
fluff entertainment that's perfectly
fine but the romantic comedies that move
us that that raise our spirits that
thrill our hearts are the ones that
embody in some fashion in some of the
characters joy dignity passion or
integrity and those are the ones we
remember though
of the classics and here again I think
if you are looking to do a romantic
comedy that many people will relate to
and many people will remember and want
to see over and over again get one of
those four qualities in there at least
one with at least some of your main
characters once again nothing wrong with
having you know fluff fluff is okay but
I like and you see that people continue
to like the romantic comedies that
really deal with the kind of love that
uplifts and not just romantic but also
we have familial we've got some
bestfriend
romances in the book and at age
differences you know young love older
love age differences love so all kinds
of love but they need to embody one of
those four qualities to really be let's
say to have the romantic in all capital
letters how would someone know that a
script that they've written is maybe
shallow versus having one or two or more
of those four qualities that's an
excellent question because it implies
that we all have the ability to a see
our own work with a clear eye and most
of us don't and that's why it's good to
have you know your friends or readers or
other people give you feedback whether
you're in a writing group or you're
working with you know some other people
that are that are doing that for you and
with you but I would say take a look at
does anybody in your story actually make
a positive change in their personality I
think there should always be some
element of sacrifice and remember that
the word sacrifice means to make sacred
so that could mean elevating someone's
opinion of themselves by saying
you're an amazing dancer has no one ever
told you that before
or wow those things that you've been
doing for the kids you've been helping
that's incredible some moment of
recognition that lifts somebody up to a
higher plane if you've got that in your
story that it's not gonna be shallow
okay okay so let's say oh sorry
Sleepless in Seattle like if we took one
of the the scripts at what point did did
Tom Hanks character maybe or even may
Ryan did they get lifted up to a higher
plane Sleepless in Seattle is such a
popular film so many people really
really seem to identify with it and
liked it so much I think part of that is
because you have two people one who's
broken hearted and one who's
dissatisfied with her fiance and their
relationship oh and then a third person
the little boy who wants a new mommy
right okay so you've got three people
who are wounded or troubled and where
you see them starting to rise up is when
meg Ryan hears on the radio Tom Hanks
voice and talking about his wife and the
magic they had between them and she
realizes that's what I want so that's
her first step upwards and then she
starts looking at her relationship is
there enough there to justify a marriage
Wow I want that kind of passion I heard
in that man's voice and then so she
sacrifices a sure thing to go after a
voice on a radio seriously okay Tom
Hanks then has to sacrifice his clinging
to his grief which is a very natural
thing that people tend to do but he has
to get over himself no not get over the
loss but get over himself so you see
both of them so you see both of them
consciously making a choice to leave
where they were and to take a step up
and then the little boy is so great you
know he's what does he sacrifice oh
nothing he's just out there manipulating
and pulling the strings but it's all for
a good cause it's something you said in
the last question reminds me of the
missed opportunities scenario and I know
when I was a little girl there was a
section in our newspaper where I grew up
about missed opportunities I'll never
forget this one post was about a man
that saw some woman he described her and
he said we we shared a moment and if
that's you can you please call me and
I've never forgotten that post and I
mean this was pre Craigslist you know I
know all that exists now but why are we
so enthralled with the idea of missed
opportunity a missed opportunity is a
factor of idealism because that
opportunity is not fact it's an
opportunity it's a possibility and onto
that we can cast all of our dreams and I
think most of us have had those moments
you know the glance across a room you're
crossing a street you look at somebody
they look at you and you go yeah and
then you both walk about do you think
should I just go stand on that street
corner forever and wait for them to come
by again and some people do but I think
the thing about a missed opportunity
most at its core the reason that it
reaches us so deeply is it offers that
question what if and we could see might
that have been the perfection that deep
in our hearts we are all striving for so
do most romantic comedies feature the
missed opportunity or the sort of even
if it's just a friend at a wedding that
they see across the table that they say
hello to isn't that sort of the core
because the what if yes the missed
opportunity can be the storyline of an
entire film or the main storyline of it
for instance in Four Weddings and a
funeral the Hugh Grant character
it definitely has a missed opportunity
through line and fortunately he resolves
it and he and Andie MacDowell get
together again but within the three part
structure of a romantic comedy that's
the that's the sad part about and the
tense part about that second section
yeah you saw what it could be and now
it's gone because one of you had to move
or somebody got in the way or someone
else's you know in positions of
propriety are keeping you apart and so
that missed opportunity which is a
vessel if you will for idealism and
perfection really bothers us and we are
driven to pursue what might be a perfect
situation and now it's a romantic comedy
and they always stop when the people get
together right so we don't have to get
into the part about dissolution and
domesticity and all that stuff but we
get to keep that illusion of perfection
and that idealism in a romantic comedy
it seems like each character each sort
of partner of this dance is missing
something in their lives and they see at
some point that that other person is
going to basically cure them of that why
do we why do we resonate with that and
why is that such a common theme there's
another wonderful Greek myth that says
that originally humans were both male
and female together and we had four legs
and four arms and two heads then we were
joined but with all those limbs humans
were able to start climbing up Mount
Olympus and were able to start
challenging the gods and the gods said
oh no this will never do and so they
tore humans apart
male and female were separated and since
then it is the nature of our yearning to
try to reunite into the one form so
that's how a mythology set it up what we
are trying to do in romance is to find
that missing part of ourselves what I
think is interesting is that in some
instances people are trying to find that
thing that will compliment them because
they don't have it and then there are
those instances where somebody says oh
you've got that so much more than I do
I'm gonna look a whole lot better than
you by comparison
you know if I'm cynical but you're more
cynical that's gonna make me look like
the good guy so some of the romantic
comedies have that sort of a mechanism
in it but I think basically what most of
us are looking for in our romantic
situations is a completion what we see
in our romantic relationships is often
said to be a reflection of our
relationship with our higher spiritual
selves or with the higher energies or
with the cosmos that we we connect to
life through each other that we connect
to the one life by relating closely to
one person and so the alchemy of love
can actually truly lift us up and that
that is what a lot of us are looking for
even if we're not conscious of it but we
are looking for that that that bliss
that nirvana within our love
relationships and you may have heard
some version of this where people say we
kissed and the world disappeared and we
became gods you go oh yes please that's
wonderful and one of my favorite authors
Lawrence Durrell British author author
of the wonderful Alexandria quartet
which is all about love and one of his
characters makes a note and say
in loving Justine I was loving all women
because she stood for the female and so
I think that's what we do to even who we
don't realize that we just go oh I love
you
we're also loving the essence of love
why so often opposites attract
why is it sort of the the hero worshiper
or shy admirer and the you know sort of
I don't know if you want to say type a
sort of here I mean I'm thinking of
let's say Jerry Maguire yes yes
absolutely love uh-huh
but but that's a common scenario whether
it's one is the male one is the food you
know that you can kind of switch who's
sort of the hero worshiper but why do we
love that scenario so much I think we
have to go back to evolutionary biology
and evolutionary psychology to truly
answer that in small groups of people
you do not want to have too much
interbreeding because it's not healthy
so you need to stir up the gene pool and
so there's a phrase the brother or the
other you're going to get a better
immune system and your offspring if
you're not mating with your relatives if
you go for the other that which is
different so you take that on up to
modern times and we're still being
influenced by that we still see the
other the person who is different from
us as more of a potential mate a lot of
that's just our biology psychology from
you know 200,000 years still working on
us but I also think it's part of the the
wonderful magnetism of passion and of
sex regardless of what gender the body
is to have the positive pole and the
negative pole that's when you get
magnetism you get to positive poles
together what happens nothing they repel
each other right but you get positive
and negative together and then you get
sparks then you get the magnetic pull so
I think that part of that opposites
attract
is built into human nature that is
trying to produce the best offspring and
part of it also is just our sense of
adventure
let's take Annie Hall so you have Woody
Allen's character who's kind of self
effacing he's down on himself and then
Diane Keaton who's a breath of fresh air
she's in a great mood she you know very
open to life why does that dynamic work
well I would counter and say it didn't
actually work because they broke up and
she in spite of her seeming
self-confidence also had some problems
with her own self-worth and what she
wanted and what she thought she should
want but yes on the surface they're
opposites and they and they attract and
it's fun and that's one of the most fun
parts about that romantic comedy but if
you look at it again I think you'll see
that there are a whole lot more alike at
heart than they are different I was
surprised at that when I went back and
watched it you know with an analytical
eye for the book at the beginning of a
romantic comedy is it best that the two
leads hate each other or intensely
dislike each other does that make us
more you know if it's if it's too
easygoing when I mean that's boring in
some sense why do we why are we
intrigued by the two you know whether
it's the co-workers or you know whatever
just you know sort of the college friend
that always sort of made fun of you or
something like that what why is that
something that's we're intrigued by I
think it goes back again to your
question about opposites attracting and
you you're not going to get any sparks
if you agree all the time this is just
not going to be interesting you know
give me somebody who challenges me also
I I have this thing I call cheetah love
and little baby cheetahs when they're
learning how to hunt you know the mom
takes them out and shows them how to
pounce and how to grab prey and how to
eat it
if you walk in to
where they are and the little baby
cheetahs are just sitting around maybe
it's not quite time to go hunting yet
but they're going to be going soon you
lay down a big chunk of bloody raw meat
in front of them they'll just look at it
they don't recognize it as lunch unless
it's running away a lot of us are the
same way about romance
we love the chase and we don't show any
interest if it's not running away so
it's part of part of some people's human
nature that they like the chase they
want to conquer something they feel that
if I didn't have to pay a price for it
it must not be worth it and that's a
hard thing when people then do get
together and the chase is over it's
often difficult then to keep the romance
going if that's been a major part of the
relationship at the beginning so is it a
good idea to start people at the
beginning of a rom-com at disparate
sides of something absolutely absolutely
because part of the fun of a rom-com is
the chase and then they get separated
and then okay now how are they going to
get back together we know what's going
to happen we just don't know how and
that's the fun of rom-coms
yes it's a predictable genre absolutely
that's why we watch it because we know
it's going to end happily or a
bittersweet maybe but we want to see how
the chase goes what tricks do they use
to win each other back or what
sacrifices do they have to make to
endear themselves again to the person
that they realize they love that takes
something where maybe it's not someone
who's chasing the the playboy but I'm
thinking of the movie green card you'd
mention Andie MacDowell earlier and
Gerard Depardieu where they're both
supposed to go in to be married and they
have to pretend that they know each
other so those types of scenarios where
it's not really that anybody's totally
at odds because I don't think if I
remember correctly that they were it was
just that they were put into this
situation
and so it's this weird thing where they
end up falling for one another acts
dentally kind of thing I don't know what
that that storyline is but I've seen it
before that sort of accidental discovery
of one another where it wasn't intended
yes you see that also in it happened to
one night and you've got a reporter and
a rich girl and you know he's trying to
get a story she's trying to get back
with her fiance who she's only engaged
to to make her dad mad because her
billionaire dad is over controlling and
so these two people come together with a
specific goal which is to get her back
to her fiance and for the story the
other reporter to get this story but
along the way then they have to pretend
like they're married and once they do
that then the accident of pretending as
if sets off even more Sparks and that
indeed is a good trope for romantic
comedies where people are thrown
together and wouldn't have even thought
that they'd like each other but once
they step into a different role with
each other and the whole pretending to
be married or pretending to be together
is a very good one I think we see that
in real life okay next time you're at
the grocery store look at the tabloids
look at those magazines what are they
all about actors and actresses who were
playing at being in love and fell in
love how often do you see that happening
the point of it is when you start acting
as if you often make it so and it's a
it's a wonderful device for romantic
comedies
now another instance where you may find
people acting as if and then falling in
love is when you're writing with
somebody and you're building these
characters you're building this
situation you're building the romance
and you're doing it they're together you
know many romances have started over I
got a great idea for a screenplay
let's write
together okay and you'll hear anybody
who's ever done this before or her knows
what can happen say yeah right you're
just writing a screenplay together
uh-huh
well we know how that goes so once again
you put two people together in a
situation where they're creating an
illusion they often start to fall into
it
and to live it so be very careful who
you're writing your rom-coms with how
much sex should a screenwriter put into
a romantic comedy screenplay from what I
have seen of the ones that I looked at
and selected and the ones I did not
select for the book I would say not much
now they can be having sex but you
probably don't want to see very much of
it because it's more about the emotions
a romantic comedy is and it's more about
the yearning it's about the barriers
between the people and certainly yeah
it's there's going to be sex but it can
start opening up so many other doors of
discussion and emotion and it can also
shift the feel of your story if you
start putting a lot of sex into it so
that's interesting mmm I think the way
that sex can shift the feel of a
romantic comedy is sex is not that funny
it's more ideally intense it's it's
passionate now can you have fun in sex
absolutely but in a romantic comedy
we're talking about yearning and we're
talking about desire we're not so much
talking about fulfillment on the screen
the fulfillment comes after the end of
the movie okay so by putting a lot of
sex into the film I think you run the
risk of diluting
the romance and the comedy now this is
not at all to say that sex isn't where
it's going because yeah but but I think
you have to keep in mind the tone of the
film and that sex can take us into many
many other deeper emotional levels do
you want to do that or do you want to
keep it more on the the yearning
idealistic fun the search part of the
story now a film where the sex actually
is important in the romantic comedy is
in moonstruck and there's this moment
not long after Nicolas Cage and Cher
have met she's engaged to his brother
the brothers going back to Sicily for a
family visit says talk my younger
brother into coming to the wedding so
she goes to meet the younger brother and
oh my gosh sparks fly and he has this
wonderful speech something to the effect
of I don't care if I burn in hell I
don't care if you burn in hell I want
you now we should be together and he
picks her up and takes her upstairs to
his bedroom and they have wild mad
passionate sex okay so in moonstruck the
passionate sex that they have starts to
affect everybody else in the story
because everyone else has to start
realizing that they don't have that kind
of passion and they want it so that's an
instance where sex really makes a
difference and is appropriate for that
story how important is the first kiss in
a romantic comedy
it is maybe the most important moment
followed closely by the one towards the
end where the two people realize and
admit to each other their love for each
other but that first kiss wow that's
that's amazing that's that's when you're
standing on the threshold of paradise
and that's when you know whether or not
it's going to work
because if that kiss does not transport
your characters does not turn on all the
lights and all the bells and whistles
and the fireworks and all the people
talk about in poetry and literature for
thousands and thousands of years if
that's not there there's no story
there's no story so building up to the
first kiss you need to have that tension
that push-pull so that when you get
there and the positive and the negative
come together
sparks do fly thinking of pretty woman
so there's the implication of sex
there's definitely the you know the sort
of the agreement the business
arrangement but but I'm trying to
remember does that actually happen until
they actually have the first kiss and
actually feels something for one another
that's when it happens okay is that that
first kiss yes now I think they've been
feeling a comradeship they've been
feeling admiration they've been having
fun they've been finding that they do
agree on some things and not others and
so there is an affinity there's
definitely an affinity and you're right
they presumably have been having sex and
she's a pro so okay you figure it's got
to be pretty good but that moment of
actually kissing is when the magic
really starts to happen
and that also now remember she was a
professional escort there is a reason
why among people who are sex workers
there's no kissing allowed because that
creates a let's say an energetic
electrical etheric esoteric connection
between people that really does
something it can change everything it
seems like to with those two characters
once they got out of their roles because
his role of was of the here I'm gonna
pay you and you're kind of beneath me
and I'm I'm this prestigious businessman
and she's like oh who do you think you
are and I've seen the guys like you
you're a dime a dozen but once they got
out of those identities and they became
real that's when it seemed like the real
kiss and the real sort of relationship
happened because they stopped being
their element sort of yeah that's a good
point when they just became themselves
and not the masks and not the costumes I
like that I like that man there's a
wonderful line in Jerry Maguire before
they have sex the first time and he says
you know sex changes everything and she
says oh I hope so and what I love too is
the sister and I want to talk about that
the sister in Jerry Maguire and the
wonderful scene where she's having her
women's group and he comes in and you
can just tell he there's a few women in
the crowd that made me look at him with
a Deering and endearing eyes but there
are just daggers pointed his way and
just the the Jiminy Cricket friend
either the one that's either trying to
talk them out of it or the one that's
trying to talk them into the
relationship I I want to talk about that
role of the the third person that sort
of either tries to bring them together
or separate them when I first started
selecting films for the book Ken Lee
publisher said you have to include
trainwreck
I went train wreck I wouldn't even go
see that I said why would I want know
this
about people's relationships getting
better you'd want to see trainwreck he
said go see trainwreck I could not
believe it it's really good and it has
in it the qualities of joy and dignity
and passion and integrity I was so
surprised now one of the reasons it does
is because the Jiminy Cricket character
the best friend is LeBron James okay
that works mhm and he is best friends
with Bill Hader and he sees something in
Amy Schumer he sees what she can be and
he convinces the two of them to get back
together and to admit their feelings for
each other so that's a wonderful
instance of that a different kind of
love triangle that you've pointed out
where you've got the lovers and then
that third person who helps them see
what it is that they have or what they
could have let's see when the third
person is actually trying to prevent
them from being together because it's
like if you take pretty woman and I
forget his name but you know George
Costanza character on Seinfeld the one
that that's his business partner and
pretty and and and he's kind of this
negative force and and and sort of
antagonizing them so that third person
as the one that's trying to prevent them
from being together yes you need the
third person either helping them because
they're not wanting to get together or
as you described trying to keep them
apart well you need that for dramatic
tension and also we need the secondary
characters to help tell us things about
the main characters so they can make
those statements you know when you say
oh I can't have them I can't have him
saying that he'd never say that about
himself we'll give the line to his
friend or give the line to her friend
who says ah you have you no idea what
this guy's like so they the third
character yes it's very very important
in any script all of the secondary
characters need some
how to be showing us something about the
main characters or they don't need to be
there now whether it's they are people
that the main characters do something to
or with or for but they are there to
service the main characters in the
storytelling our romantic comedy is
driven by plot or character as a genre
that has three parts the plots just
there
you know you get together you get apart
and then you get back together so I
don't think it's so much plot that
drives it as it is character that's
where we find our interest is in the
people and how diverse are they and how
opposite are they or where are their
similarities what is it that took them
apart and how will they possibly get
back together and who's helping them do
that and who's against them doing that
so it's more about character I think in
a romantic comedy because it's a genre
and it has its tropes and it has its
steps and if those aren't happening then
you don't have a romantic comedy
so character is I think the most
important thing and that's what you
should be focusing on let's talk about
the character archetypes because you
have as I was saying earlier sort of the
hero worshiper you had the sort of the
type a ambitious that doesn't have time
for relationship you might have sort of
the hot girl that no guy is sort of good
enough for or similar with the guy and
then you have sort of the shot you know
what are some of the archetypes that we
typically see in romantic comedies
either as a friend or as the protagonist
some of the typical archetypes and in
the book I did have on there's a whole
section in each movie about the lover
types and indeed a lot of what you just
mentioned there's the cynical person now
that's always a real good one somebody
who's been burned and disappointed in
love so the cynic is a wonderful
archetype and I like that definition
that a cynic is just a wounded romantic
so seeing that character change and go
through a character arc can be very
satisfying to us
also the person who doesn't even realize
they need love the clueless no it's
different from being a cynic but the
clueless person is just oh no
everything's fine
okay maybe I'm in a loveless
relationship but you know it's
convenient it works so they need to be
waked up so they're the archetype of the
person who needs to be awakened that
just kind of what Wow Oh and then you've
got another good one is the bossy person
who's always right and always in charge
or always wants to be anyway and then
the person who and I think this is so
well done and down with love where
you've got even McGregor is the the type
a confident always in charge you know
and he's a he's running the show and all
of course all the women love him he's
got you know many many many many
girlfriends and then you have Renee
Zellweger who is the formerly mousy
secretary who I love this and your
writers I think will all just roll their
eyes she says well you weren't paying
any attention to me and so I decided I
was just gonna go off and I was gonna
write a book and so I did and then it
became a best-seller international and
then I said and I went to see it with uh
some writers and we all went
I always thought have I supposed to work
right
you just write something and it becomes
an instant international bestseller okay
so she was the person who was waking up
now she was waking herself up but
bringing the two of them together made a
really dynamic energy exchange in that
film down with love so the the various
archetypes you can go from the the
disappointed in love to the still
grieving and must love dogs Christopher
Plummer has a wonderful line he's father
who's a widow and he says no I know I've
had the love of my life
and they'll never ever be anyone to take
her place but I'm just out there tap
dancing as fast as I can
having some fun and just hoping I won't
notice all the time what I've lost and
it's very sad but it's also very hopeful
so many many character types can play a
part in a romantic comedy and by
choosing different types than what you
would think you can make a much more
interesting story if they're an
antagonist or a dark side to romantic
comedies and antagonist or a dark side I
think in romantic comedies the
antagonist is either within or usually
just without but not big okay we take
three levels of opposition there's
internal and then there's opposition
from those around you family society
culture and then on a bigger level of
stories there's the opposition from the
big outside you know bureaucracies
aliens you know tsunamis but in a
romantic comedy you want antagonists and
opposition just at those two levels the
close two levels it's a this is a small
story we're not taking on the world
we're not trying to overthrow kingdoms
so your opposition can be an another
person or a bunch of people family
society culture sometimes religion but
usually not because it can be problems
in them trying to have a comedy to get
into you know those deeper philosophical
questions but so often the main
antagonist is within one's own self take
for instance my best friend's wedding
Julia Roberts main antagonist was
herself and what she thought she should
have and how she thought it should be
and that was enough opposition to carry
that whole film
because there was no one else against
her now the situation was against her
because the guy was engaged and he was
getting married but nobody was coming
against her in particular she was doing
it all to herself in My Big Fat Greek
Wedding you had both those levels the
insecurity and then the family saying
well no you got to marry a nice Greek
boy and be Greek like you're a great
person
be a great person so two levels four
antagonists and opposition in a romantic
comedy and he said earlier that before
starting this book you weren't a huge
fan of romantic comedies but what films
did you actually enjoy of that genre
well I did have my favorites already
and certainly Love Actually is my
favorite because it's got so many
different love stories in it of so many
different types and it's so well crafted
every writer should watch and
deconstruct Love Actually to see how you
can create and sustain character arcs
many of them over the course of a film
and have what seven eight ten storylines
going on and they all work together and
they're all interconnected and it's it's
brilliant it's brilliant writing and
filmmaking and the stories and the
characters are so endearing so love
actually I do like down with love and
Mamma Mia because it's so much fun to
sing to seriously can you watch Mamma
Mia and not sing no you can't we talked
about what a screenwriter should know
about the confessional moment in writing
a romantic comedy is that a crises is
where they break down they've been
beaten down they just have to get this
off their chest or how does that work
yes typically it is something has
cracked and when we talked earlier about
the opposition being internal it's the
moment when a
character realizes what they are doing
is not helping them to get what they
want and that they have to ask for
forgiveness or they have to change
something in themselves they have to
once again sacrifice something in order
to get that greater thing that they
desire a couple of good examples of that
are when Mel Gibson is apologizing in
what women want and it's a beautiful
apology there's another really good one
in you've got mail when Tom Hanks
apologizes what's interesting there
though is he's apologizing for being two
different people and he's apologizing
for being you know the guy who shut down
her book store but also for being the
guy that she was in love with online and
not letting her know that he was both
guys so he has a two-fold apology
there's also an interesting one in
Romancing the stone which is a fun
romantic comedy that's also adventure
and so that moment of the apology is
that moment when someone realizes
they've got to change in order to get
what they want so there's still a little
bit of selfishness in it but if they do
it well if they do it with humility and
integrity it can work however Mantic
comedy is evolved over the years I mean
you know we have trainwreck when you I
mean and I don't even know if the
graduates really a romantic comedy but
totally different films you know in
terms of to the way that humor is
approached and so however the years over
the decades have romantic comedies
changed or maybe they haven't what it
looks like to me from having looked at
romantic comedies from way back in the
30s on up to today is that like a lot of
films they used to be more clever in the
dialog we had snappier dialogue there
were it was a sharper sense of humor
there was
intelligence and wit at play that I
think we've lost some of and that's just
a cultural shift people communicate
differently now whether it's because of
social media or you know globalization
there's just not as much witty banter as
there used to be in the romantic
comedies also you've seen a shifting in
sexual attitudes and what's allowed
remember that for a lot of the older
films they were being made under the
Hays Code which was a code imposed on
Hollywood that you couldn't say certain
things you couldn't deal with certain
topics you couldn't have overt sexuality
so you get all these wonderful innuendos
right and you get the wonderful the look
well you don't have to see the people in
bed together you know that's where it's
going okay so there's a lot of subtlety
and really really good writing in the
older films because of those constraints
so now when anything goes often I think
people cut to the chase too soon and
what we like is the chase otherwise
frankly you're just watching porn
you know you need the story for it to
really be engaging on those emotional
and mental levels so how I've seen them
change a lot is that what in how I've
seen them change a lot is in what you're
actually going to see on screen as well
as the dialog and the interaction
between the characters either being more
constrained and more difficult to get
together or easier to get together and
then you sometimes and unfortunately it
doesn't work very well you have to
fabricate reasons for people to be in
conflict curious about this Hays Code
when did sort of those rules get lifted
I do not know the answer to that okay I
think it was in the early 60s oh but
that's something your writers should
look up mm-hmm because it was a very
very interesting time what god impose
on writing and filmmaking and seeing how
clever writers worked around it and
still got to say what they wanted to say
but it used to be if in that era if you
committed adultery you had to die if you
were the mistress you had to die if you
were the person who did this you had to
die and usually it was the blonde
because we were upholding you know the
truth the American Way the American
family and all this hypocrisy but also
you know codes of behavior it's a very
very interesting time and also look into
the whole blacklist era as well they
kind of went hand in hand it's a it's a
really good look for writers to look
back and see the constraints that are
often placed on writers and how to get
around it and still tell wonderful
stories sure I know the notorious Bettie
Page they sort of touched on all that
but then the Summer of Love came so I
don't know if that's like 68 but things
definitely changed and then it was
totally different and you had you know
where it was expected that people were
swapping partners and things like that
so it's it's changed whereas now it
seems like it's more sort of online
hookup so you see how the culture
changes how these people get together
and it's interesting but you said
something earlier about maybe it being
wrong here now do you think we'll ever
go back to another time where maybe
people will be like you know what I'm
too desensitized to all this because
even driving around Los Angeles you see
billboards that you're like wow I'm just
shocked that that would be out there but
it's part of the culture now it's
expected to see certain images it is and
I think if we take a long view we see
that these sorts of things come and go
everything is cyclic now what I hope
would not happen is that there is
repression because down that road lies
well repression and all the bad stuff
that comes with that but what I would
rather see is a raising
sensibilities like what you just said
you know there's too much of that it's
like also I think what you risk and here
again raunchy is in style right now it's
a fad and so many of the stand-up comics
and the comedies are raunchy comedies
what I think we lose now not to be
censoring any of that but what I think
we lose is the sense of romance again
and I I hear a lot of particularly
younger people saying they wish things
were more romantic they wish they had
the situations that they have read about
that they've seen in the movies but it's
just not like that right now so I think
what you may be finding is people
wanting more romance because it's
exhilarating
it's thrilling and unless you've got a
bit of distance unless you've got a bit
of the hidden unless you've got some of
the unobtainable you're not going to
have the striving and the yearning that
is what makes romance so going back to
that article or that little post I saw
in my hometown newspaper about you know
I saw you when you're wearing this and
you look like this and we shared a
moment and please and here's my number
area code for one you know that that
we've lost that and for me I'm still
remembering who was that man who was
that woman yes what was it about her
that was so you know how it would just
be like I mean there's just
you could probably swipe look right or
left on one of these social networks and
tinder grind or whatever and find who
that person is but I'm not sure really
really I'm going with it I guess it just
it seems like it'd be nice to go back to
that but you're saying so you hear from
a lot of Millennials that they kind of
miss like the notebook and that was
probably before most Millennials were
watching films I think that was what
early 2000s or something so yeah so so
it sounds like oh right around that time
things started to change
so now we get more very open sexual talk
but a lot of the human emotion in terms
of the yearning is gone I think it's
important to keep in mind the various
levels of our interactions with each
other and sex is easy sex is easy to get
okay
not a problem in our culture anyway love
fortunately is pretty well widespread -
you've got familial love and friendship
love and you know love of people who are
involved in it's a similar cause so love
is pretty prevalent but passion is rare
and precious and that's what romantic
comedies ideally and the ones that end
up being classics are giving us they're
showing us passion and you can't have
passion without yearning and you can't
have yearning without a buildup and you
can't have a buildup without and ideal
something that to be yearning for like
that missed opportunity so if you want
to get the most out of that first kiss
and the first Boff or whatever then you
have to build up the energy that's just
physics you have to build up the charge
of energy and then when those points
come together then you get the fireworks
and how does a writer build that up
that's that's a great point well it
could even be as simple as a line that
says he walks towards her she can see
what's on his mind and then he turns
away and then you go to her and she's
going but but and then you have another
preview so you almost get people - it's
teasing okay it's foreplay if you will
for the emotions as well as you know
eventually it'll seep over into the
physicalities of the love but it's think
of it as foreplay for the emotions it's
teasing it's oh do they oh I don't know
Oh what about this and almost getting
there and then pulling away so it's a
real dance it's a real dance like the
crossing and the
walk like the crossing in the crosswalk
yeah yeah but you have to build up the
tension for there to be any charge so
when a screenwriter finally finishes
their screenplay and this could apply to
romantic comedies or horror or whatever
what's the standard protocol of steps
that they should go through after they
finish it up well as a consultant I'm a
bit prejudiced but I think they should
seek professional opinion and there are
a number of really wonderful well
experienced story consultants that are
available and so get someone who's a
professional to read your script and
give you commentary on it and often more
than one person because you know
everybody's got their own opinion even
though they know about story and of
course register it with the writers
guild be sure you do that before it goes
to you know any potential buyers and
then start taking a look at the places
to place your story and for instance the
great American pitch fest is a wonderful
opportunity for writers you go there you
attend classes listen to panels on
writing and selling and then there's a
whole day of live pitching opportunities
where you can go in and pitch your
romantic comedy script and hopefully
find people who are interested in it
producers production companies
development executives agents managers
there are a couple of live pitchfest
great American pitch fest is the best
one it's fabulous then there are also
virtual pitch fests and there are
listing places like Inc tip is a good
one so you can write your synopsis and
put your story up there get it listed
and many many many producers and people
looking for stories go to these places
to find them so put it out there but now
do this after you've consulted with
somebody who is an expert on story and
knows the business and try to go to some
of the conference's some of them are
happening online now but try to attend
some Story conferences
if you haven't already and then write up
your synopsis your pitch and you can get
help with that too on how to write good
pitches and effective pitches and then
start putting it out there it's easier
now than it used to be Wow
because there are so many new venues and
there's so many production companies and
you can even do it yourself you can you
know make your own movie a lot of people
do for not much money at all and then
just put it up on YouTube or Vimeo but I
would say do get feedback get
professional feedback be sure you
register it and then look at the various
outlets for exposing your script to
people who are buying the virtual pitch
vests the listing services and great
American pitch vest and see what kind of
feedback you get and make improvements
if you think that they're good
suggestions if not stick to what you've
got and persist persist persist persist
persist and I'll tell one little quick
story about that back in 1977 one of my
writing partners and I wrote a script
and we had it and we were rewriting it
and we got feedback and this and that
and at one point it was under
consideration at MGM before a regime
change you know and then everything goes
away and everybody starts over so we'd
had this script for a long time we
entered it into a script contest year or
so ago and it was one of the winners and
we got a trip to the Bahamas for a
writer's retreat and somebody said wow
that's great
how long did it take you guys we went
well we started in 1977 so it took a
long time but you see you just keep
doing it and keep getting it out there
and you may well eventually have your
dream come true it's curious when you
decided to submit for this this contest
how much did you change it for the time
frame not at all
because it's an historical script anyway
okay yeah okay interesting
yeah it's said in Cuba Cuba's opening up
we said AHA now it's the time let's pull
that script back out and get it out
there so we entered a number of contests
and you know placed here and place there
and got in this mention and that so it
got good feedback it got good results so
yeah what does this persist persist
one last question though and that is
what if someone says you know I finished
my script I've shown it to someone in my
family and then three of my college
buddies and one of them is an English
major and I know they're gonna give me
the truth is that enough because maybe
they're not in the industry it's good
but it's not enough and specifically for
the reason you just said they're not in
the industry
it's important to get non industry
feedback because that's your eventual
audience is the people sitting in the
theatres or the people tuning in on
Netflix or watching your piece on Vimeo
so you want civilians to give you some
feedback but as far as is your structure
working are your characters
well-developed is your plot pasted well
enough and what's the market place you
need to go to the professionals for that
because it's a very crowded marketplace
and you need professional help in order
to know how to approach it